Trascrizione: Federico Sangati
Revisore: Fatbardha Hoxha
Siamo entrati in questo teatro oggi
con almeno una certezza:
l'essere umano è l'essere senziente
più evoluto del sistema solare.
Non c'è nessun essere vivente
in grado di creare
strutture economiche, culturali e sociali
così complesse come gli esseri umani.
Questa certezza è talmente radicata in noi
che pensiamo di essere fuori
da una corsa evolutiva delle specie
e quindi aver raggiunto
un traguardo cognitivo
non più raggiungibile
da nessun essere vivente.
Siamo sicuri che sia così?
In realtà, noi stessi stiamo contribuendo
a creare un'intelligenza,
quella artificiale,
che potrebbe superarci presto o tardi.
Fino agli anni 50
molti studiosi e ricercatori
si sono dedicati
all'Intelligenza Artificiale
per creare delle macchine
che potessero risolvere
dei problemi molto complessi,
quindi che non eravamo in grado
di risolvere in altre maniere.
Queste intelligenze si basano fin d'allora
su modelli matematico-statistici
in grado di fornire
gli elementi computazionali
in uno specifico dominio, così che
la macchina possa apprendere quel dominio,
fare delle categorizzazioni
e dare delle previsioni
rispetto a degli scenari
che noi gli presentiamo.
Ora, non suona molto intelligente
come definizione,
però è quello che le macchine fanno
in questo momento.
Quello che gli attribuisce intelligenza
siamo noi:
quando vediamo
un comportamento intelligente
pensiamo che quell'agente
effettivamente lo sia.
In realtà tutta l'Intelligenza Artificiale
in questo momento
si basa fondamentalmente
sulla capacità computazionale.
Quindi questi oggetti hanno
una capacità computazionale enorme.
Questo tipo di intelligenza artificiale
viene chiamata
intelligenza artificiale debole,
in contrapposizione con il concetto di
intelligenza artificiale forte,
dove si teorizza la possibilità
di far ragionare delle macchine,
dar loro autocoscienza, e farle ragionare
in maniera simile all'essere umano.
Questi due concetti hanno varie sfumature
di intelligenza che possiamo identificare.
La prima sono le macchine reattive
che sono il primo stadio di questo tipo
di intelligenze.
Cosa riescono a fare?
Riescono ad analizzare un dominio,
estrarre un ventaglio di possibilità
e scegliere quella migliore
per uno scopo specifico.
Qui vedete nell'immagine Deep Blue,
che è forse una delle prime e più famose
intelligenze artificiali di IBM,
che ha sconfitto il campione mondiale
di scacchi, Kasparov, già nel 96
quando Kasparov, solo qualche anno prima,
aveva battuto 32 computer
contemporaneamente.
Quindi comincia ad aumentare
la capacità di calcolo
e l'anno scorso Google tira fuori AlphaGo
che è un'intelligenza artificiale
che gioca a Go.
Go è un gioco molto più complesso
degli scacchi
e si pensava che AlphaGo
non potesse battere un essere umano.
Invece l'anno scorso Lee Sedol,
che è il campione Sud Coreano,
è stato battuto da questa macchina.
Ne è uscita un'altra
giusto qualche mese fa
che si chiama AlphaGo Zero
che per la prima volta
riesce ad apprendere da sola:
mentre AlphaGo si basava
sull'esperienza umana,
per battere gli esseri umani,
AlphaGo Zero si basa
sulla sua sola esperienza.
Ha giocato in tre giorni qualcosa come
300 milioni di partite
e adesso straccia qualunque versione
precedente di Alfa Go.
Quindi questa è la tipica
Intelligenza Artificiale
che abbiamo in questo momento.
Le prossime sono quelle
che vengono chiamate
Intelligenze Artificiali
a memoria limitata.
Cosa fanno queste Intelligenze?
Iniziano a percepire
il mondo che li circonda.
Quindi vengono dotate di sensori
con cui riescono a creare
una rappresentazione
abbastanza affidabile
dello spazio e del tempo.
Hanno una memoria limitata
quindi non riescono a mantenere,
come il cervello, queste esperienze,
ma possono comunque interagire
in maniera molto più sofisticata.
Questo esempio è una macchina
a guida autonoma
ed è quello che si avvicina di più
in questo momento
a questo tipo di intelligenze.
Abbiamo poi una tipologia
di cui non abbiamo ancora esempi
che sono macchine
che si riferiscono alla teoria della mente
Quindi aggiungiamo una caratteristica:
percepisco il mondo,
capisco spazio e tempo
e qui capisco anche
che ho degli agenti intelligenti
che non sono degli oggetti fisici
e quindi hanno dei pensieri,
delle emozioni e delle motivazioni.
Devo quindi agire di conseguenza,
inizio a interagire con l'essere umano
in contesti sociali e culturali diversi,
e con le emozioni:
capisco quando l'essere umano
non vuole essere scocciato,
se è arrabbiato o felice.
L'ultimo stadio
di Intelligenza Artificiale
è quello delle Intelligenze Artificiali
autocoscienti.
Qui siamo lontanissimi
da arrivare a questo punto,
tant'è che non comprendiamo bene
nemmeno la coscienza umana
o che cosa significa "autocoscienza",
qui è ancora una tabula rasa.
Quindi ci stiamo concentrando
sul perfezionamento
delle macchine reattive
e sull'evoluzione
di quelle a memoria limitata.
Non sono solo intelligenze artificiali
da laboratorio o da gioco
e sperimentazione.
Parliamo di intelligenze artificiali
che voi avete già, le state già usando.
Avete un portale
verso questa Intelligenza Artificiale
che è il vostro smartphone.
Vi fa accedere ad assistenti virtuali
come Siri, Cortana, Google Now, ...
Questo tipo di assistenti virtuali
si basa su algoritmi di Machine Learning
con in più degli algoritmi
di analisi comportamentale
per personalizzare la risposta
sulle vostre esigenze.
Anche qui ci si basa essenzialmente
sulla capacità computazionale
e in più sui dati.
I dati sono molto importanti
perché queste intelligenze artificiali,
come la maggior parte del futuro,
si baseranno su dati prodotti da voi.
Voi siete il carburante
di queste intelligenze,
sia per perfezionarle,
sia per farle evolvere.
Quindi abbiamo un sacco di dati
che sono nostri
che vengono messi a disposizione
di macchine
e controllate da soggetti molto specifici
in particolare le "big company"
dell'industria informatica.
Con un passo proattivo
di autoregolamentazione
molte di queste Industrie Hi-Tech
hanno detto:
"Ok, facciamo una partnership,
dimostriamo che l'intelligenza artificiale
è una cosa bella e positiva,
ci si può fare un sacco di cose,
ed elenchiamo delle linee guida
che noi seguiremo
in modo che siamo sicuri
che queste intelligenze artificiali
faranno quello che serve".
In questo modo
si cerca di non sterilizzare
un mercato nascente
e molto promettente.
Un filino contro a questa opinione
è questo signore,
che vi cito perché dice cose interessanti
anche se lo ho tradotto,
[Sono a contatto con Intelligenza
Artificiale veramente d'avanguardia ...
e penso che le persone...
dovrebbero essere davvero
preoccupate a riguardo.
Continuo a suonare
il campanello d'allarme,
ma fino a quando le persone non vedranno
robot in giro per le strade
non sapranno come reagire
perché tutto appare così vago.]
e ancora
[L'Intelligenza Artificiale...
è un raro caso in cui
abbiamo bisogno di essere proattivi
nella regolamentazione
invece che reattivi.
Io penso che nel momento in cui
saremo reattivi nella regolamentazione...
dell'Intelligenza Artificiale,
sarà troppo tardi.]
Questo lo dice Elon Musk,
che per i pochi che non lo conoscessero
è un visionario, contemporaneo,
imprenditore
l'uomo che è dietro
ad aziende straordinarie
come SpaceX
che per la prima volta nella storia
è stata in grado di realizzare
razzi riutilizzabili
quindi aprendo l'esplorazione spaziale
e la colonizzazione di altri pianeti
per il genere umano.
Ha fondato aziende tipo Tesla
che si concentra
sul rendere tutta l'energia
del mondo come sostenibile
facendo centrali solari
a energia pulita e realizzando ad esempio
le prime macchine elettriche
a guida autonoma,
quindi uno che di tecnologie e previsioni
se ne intende.
Questa frase l'ha detta
di fronte al governo americano
in un'audizione pubblica
proprio per sensibilizzare,
ed è raro per un imprenditore americano,
sostiene che ci vuole un controllo
che venga assolutamente
anteposto all'innovazione.
Ovviamente Mask
non si immagina i Terminator
che si rivoltano all'essere umano
non c'è assolutamente bisogno
di arrivare fino a là.
Il punto è che
le Intelligenze Artificiali
non occorre che siano intelligenti
per fare cose straordinarie,
almeno per il concetto di intelligenza
che intendiamo noi.
Il punto è che le intelligenze
si stanno concentrando
nelle mani di pochissimi soggetti
e diventano quindi un'arma
assolutamente potente
verso la quale superato un certo punto
non ci potremmo più ribellare.
Ma come è fatta sostanzialmente
un'Intelligenza Artificiale?
Ci sono tantissimi modi per farla.
Quelli più efficienti prevedono
l'interazione di un'infinità di sistemi,
sistemi che interagiscono tra di loro,
elaborano dati e danno risultati
quindi immaginiamo dei sensori,
delle lavorazioni e degli attuatori.
Questo tipo di architetture ha bisogno
di un sacco di caratteristiche tecniche.
Parliamo di affidabilità dei dati,
certificazione, velocità, banda, ...
tutta una serie di cose
che noi effettivamente
possiamo ritrovare
in qualcosa che abbiamo già
e cioè la rete Internet.
Internet nasce come una rete distribuita.
Purtroppo nel tempo,
per questioni pratiche prima
e opportunistiche poi,
pian piano diventa una
rete sempre più centralizzata
quindi dove dei soggetti
generano, monitorano e gestiscono
praticamente tutto il traffico mondiale.
Con l'aumento della qualità di servizi
che Internet offre,
si ha un aumento spasmodico di utenti.
Cosa succede?
A questo punto i tecnici dicono:
"Non ce la facciamo,
l'infrastruttura non regge"
Cosa si fa?
Si centralizza ancora di più.
Quindi quello che adesso
voi chiamate "cloud"
in realtà sono dei giganteschi centri
di elaborazione dati
che gestiscono praticamente
quasi la totalità dell'IT mondiale
accentrando un potere incredibile.
Ora fortunatamente in parallelo
a questo tipo di tendenza,
sono nate le tecnologie che noi chiamiamo
"peer-to-peer" e quindi "tra pari"
che permettono di non passare
da dei server centrali
per poter fare un'interazione.
Ad esempio il file-sharing,
che è la condivisione di file,
oppure la messaggistica
o lo streaming video.
Ora, questo tipo di tendenza, che prima
era limitata a una scelta morale,
piuttosto che di filosofia di privacy
e trasparenza dell'informazione,
ormai sta diventando indispensabile
come approccio architetturale
perché il numero di device connessi
sta aumentando esponenzialmente.
Stiamo parlando
di decine di miliardi di device
che si inseriranno in questa rete
come utenti e vorranno interagire.
Quindi quell'infrastruttura
comunque non reggerà.
Quindi stiamo andando verso
delle architetture decentralizzate.
Cosa significa?
Significa andare a lavorare
su un'architettura
la prima e quella più famosa
e più potente in questo momento
che si chiama "Blockchain".
La Blockchain è stata resa famosa
negli ultimi anni,
in particolare dai Bitcoin,
che sono una criptovaluta
che ha inventato la Blockchain
per i suoi scopi.
Cosa si può fare con una Blockchain?
Per i non tecnici:
immaginatevi un libro mastro
di informazioni,
in cui ogni attore può scrivere qualcosa.
La cosa importante è che
non serve un'entità centrale
per governare questo tipo di rete.
Quindi le informazioni possono essere
scritte, validate e confermate
senza bisogno di un'autorità centrale.
Questo tramite meccanismi
di consenso distribuito.
È molto importante il concetto di consenso
proprio perché si responsabilizzano i nodi
e si evita di andare ad affidarsi
ai singoli soggetti.
Ora, questo tipo di architettura prevede
la possibilità di scrivere sia dei dati,
ad esempio io dò tot Bitcoin a qualcuno,
quindi una semplice
transazione finanziaria,
ma soprattutto si possono anche creare
dei piccoli programmi.
La differenza
con i programmi tradizionali è che qui
io so esattamente cosa il programma farà
a fronte di un determinato evento.
Vi faccio un esempio semplicissimo:
potrei scrivere un programma
che paga un premio assicurativo
a fronte il verificarsi di un sinistro.
Questa cosa che adesso viene fatta
da 300 soggetti
ed è passibile di modifiche,
qui non lo sarebbe.
In più questo tipo di reti
si basa su una crittografia
ai massimi livelli attuali,
quindi tutto quello che fate
con la vostra carta di credito,
l'accesso ai siti bancari
piuttosto che la messaggistica online,
queste tecnologie lo fanno
con un grado di sicurezza ancora maggiore
e sono già alcune pronte per affrontare
il problema della crittografia quantistica
e cioè la capacità di resistere
ai computer quantistici
che sono il prossimo stadio evolutivo
dei computer.
Quindi abbiamo questo tipo di rete.
Cosa possiamo fare?
A questo punto possiamo immaginare
la creazione
di un'Intelligenza Artificiale
che vada ad utilizzare dei programmi,
che si chiamano contratti intelligenti,
trasparenti
e che vincolino quello che
un'Intelligenza Artificiale può fare,
definendo i suoi confini
e le sue fondamenta,
così che l'Intelligenza Artificiale
possa evolvere
ma rimanere sotto il nostro controllo.
Cosa serve per fare questa cosa?
Serve una struttura democratica
e la partecipazione di tutti gli attori
a questo tipo di intelligenza.
Quindi cosa dobbiamo fare per realizzare
questo tipo di intelligenza?
Noi tecnici dobbiamo sicuramente
creare gli strumenti adeguati
a fornire la capacità di esprimere
la volontà in maniera democratica.
Quindi non ci deve essere un soggetto
che ci può vincolare
ad esprimere questa volontà.
Possiamo rendere
le interfacce accattivanti,
possiamo rendere le reti veloci,
possiamo fare un sacco di cose...
ma poi serve qualcuno
che faccia funzionare
questo motore intelligente,
e questo siete voi.
Voi siete quelli
che daranno i dati
e daranno le indicazioni
a questa intelligenza
Quindi cosa serve?
Serve l'impegno
ad avere la consapevolezza
del proprio ruolo.
Mentre adesso siete utenti passivi,
domani dovrete avere questa consapevolezza
se vogliamo continuare a dichiararci
la specie vivente più evoluta
del sistema solare
non più questa volta
come singoli soggetti
ma come una entità senziente collettiva.
Grazie mille!